- The purrfect greeting card
for the creepiest cat
lady in your life.
The only thing more disgusting
than your aunt's
obsession with her cat
is this card.
(laughter)
That's how just a
cat would be in you
and then exit your body.
Fur and all.
I think this image is
even more disgusting
if you imagine she put it
in there in the first place.
- [Doug] Me-ouch!
- Me-ouch!
(laughter)
- [Moshe] This is from
Hoarders Extreme Edition.
- Wait a minute.
Wait a minute.
Go back to that image.
Go back to that image
right this second.
So we can show this,
but you have to
pixelate the tits out?
(laughter)
Are you kidding me?
Well we don't want
anyone to be offended.
By a nipple,
so here's just a
cross-section of a lady
with a cat coming
out of her vagina,
but do not.
If there is one
millimeter of nipple,
s***'s going to get crazy.
(laughter and cheering)
This is what's fun.
See that big pussy come
out of that big *****.
And if my standards
and practices
calculations are correct,
only one of those got bleeped.
(cheering and applause)
- [Moshe] Hey Chris
- What?
- Points.